2020 has been like a year-long monster
mash
leading up to october and a cathartic
graveyard smash
sure the world is crazy but at least we
can look forward to that most sacred of
spooky observances
melting into our couches to binge the
most horrifying things on netflix
[Music]
just in time for sweater weather and
pumpkin flavored nouns comes another
staple of middlebrow suburban culture
troop crime documentaries specifically
netflix is set to bring new episodes of
its smash hit revival of unsolved
mysteries back to television screens on
october 19th
my hope is that there is somebody that's
out there that knows the truth
there will be six new episodes of the
critically acclaimed docu-series
exploring real-life tales of the creepy
and macabre while the subjects of the
show's forthcoming investigations have
been kept under wraps
a few hints have been dropped along the
way in july a variety interview with
showrunner terry dunn murrah
raised the question of if there would be
a ghost episode mirror replied
yes but i'll qualify that and say it's
an unusual ghost episode
that's all i'll say it's different a bit
different
based on daphne du maurier's novel of
the same name
and directed by ben wetley of the abcs
of death
rebecca stars lily james as the
fresh-faced optimistic new bride of a
wealthy widower played by one-time
lone ranger army hammer after arriving
at her husband's luxurious mansion
rebecca is greeted by the housekeeper
kristen scott thomas's mrs danvers who
makes the newly married young lady very
much aware that she doesn't have the
goods necessary to take the place of her
previous boss
i wonder what she's thinking about you
this won't be the first time that
rebecca has been adapted for the screen
in 1940 alfred hitchcock directed an
ever so
slightly toned down version of the story
which was met with critical acclaim and
even won the oscar for best picture
while the remakes of hitchcock movies
have had a rough track record
this one looks to be a real hum dinger
netflix explores the horror of the
laplands on october
22nd with its first original norwegian
motion picture
cadaver starring gitawit of the
impossible thorbern har
from vikings and the 12th man's thomas
ghoulstop
cadaver tells the story of a family
trying to survive in the wake of a
nuclear disaster
when they're invited to a local hotel
and promised a free meal in exchange for
being part of
theatrical production things take a
decidingly upsetting turn
masks are worn folks start to disappear
the line between performance and reality
begins to blur
and the buttress of rationality
splinters as a result
the film represents director jaren
hardall's first feature-length movie
after making a name for himself with
short films like clown
every win and charmingly a harry potter
fan film from 2011.
nobody sleeps in the woods tonight
follows the time-honored tradition of
sticking teenagers in the woods
and punishing them for their youthful
indiscretions slasher films have been
chopping
slicing and impaling kids for decades on
the basis of premarital relations
an appreciation for the demon weed
oafish thick headedness and so on
but this time around they'll be bumped
off for that most heinous and
contemporary of crimes
being on their phones all the time you
just
don't get it do you i have over 60 apps
on that phone what if i lost my phone
the movie produced in poland and
acquired for international distribution
by netflix tells the tale of a group of
teenagers
sent into the forest to unplug from
their devices not long after arriving
for their technological detox however
they begin to suspect there may be
something sinister lurking in the
forest's shadows
featuring a bevy of polish talent nobody
sleeps in the woods tonight
stars yulia vainbaya narcovic victoria
gasievska
and staniswa sifka in a dire story of
survival
that these days everyone can relate to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you